this gets down to a big argument in the
poker community and the academic
Community for a long time there was this
debate of like what's called GTO Game
Theory optimal poker or exploitative
play
and um up until about like 2017 when we
did the liberatis match I think actually
exploitative play had the advantage a
lot of people were saying like oh this
whole idea of Game Theory it's just
nonsense and if you really want to make
money you got to like look into the
other person's eyes and read their soul
and figure out what cards they have but
what happened was people started
adopting the game theory optimal
strategy
um and they were making good money and
they weren't trying to adapt so much the
other player they were just trying to
play the national equilibrium and then
what really solidified it I think was
the broadest the broadest match
where we played our bot against four top
heads up no limit Hold'em poker players
and the bot wasn't trying to adapt to
them it wasn't trying to exploit them it
wasn't trying to do these Mind Games it
was just trying to approximate the Nash
equilibrium and it crushed them
I think you know
it we've we're playing for 50 100 blinds
and over the course of about 120 000
hands it made close to two million
dollars 120 000 hands 120 000 hands
against humans yeah and this was this
was fake money to be clear so there was
real money at stake there was 200 000
first of all all money is fake but um
that's that's that's a different
conversation
um we give it meaning uh it's an it's a
it's a phenomena that gets meaning from
our uh complex psychology as a human
civilization
um it's emerging from the collective
intelligence of the human species but
that's not what you mean you mean like
there's literally you can't you can't
buy stuff with it okay can you actually
uh step back and take me through that
um competition yeah okay so
when I was in grad school
um there was this thing called the
annual computer poker competition where
every year all the different research
Labs that were working on AI for poker
would get together they would make a bot
they would play them against each other
uh and we made a bot that actually won
the um 2014 competition the 2016
competition uh and so we decided we're
gonna take this bot build on it and play
against Real top professional heads up
no limit Texas HoldEm Poker players
so we invited four of the world's best
players in this specialty and we
challenge them to 120 000 hands of poker
over the course of 20 days
um and we had 200 000 200 000 in prize
money at stake where it would basically
be divided among them depending on how
well they did relative to each other
so we wanted to have some incentive for
them to play their best
did you have a confidence
2014-16 that this is even possible how
much doubt was there so and we did a
competition actually in 2015 where we
also played against professional poker
players and the bot lost by by a pretty
sizable margin actually now there were
some big improvements from 2015 to 2017.
and so can you speak to the improvements
is it computational nature is it the
algorithm the the methods it was it was
really an algorithmic approach that was
the difference so 2015 it was much more
focused on trying to come up with a
strategy up front like trying to solve
the entire game of poker like and then
just have a lookup table where you're
saying like oh I'm in this situation
what's the strategy
um the approach that we took in 2017 was
much more search based it was trying to
say okay well let me in real time try to
compute a much better strategy than what
I had pre-computed by playing against
myself during self-play what is the
search space for
poker what are you searching over
what's that look like there's different
actions like raising calling yeah what
are the actions
um is it just a search over actions so
in a game like chess the the search is
like okay I'm in this chess position and
I can like you know move these different
pieces and see where things end up in
poker what you're searching over is the
actions you can take for your hand the
probabilities that you take those
actions and then also the probabilities
that you take other actions with other
hands that you might have
um and and that's kind of like a hard to
wrap your head around like why are you
searching over these like other hands
that you might have and like trying to
figure out what you would do with those
hands
um and the idea is is again you you
wanna
you wanna always be balanced and
unpredictable and so if you're a search
algorithm that's saying like oh I want
to raise with this hand well in order to
know whether that's a good action like
let's say it's a bluff you know let's
say you have a bad hand and you're
saying like oh I I think I should be
betting here with this really bad hand
and bluffing well that all that's only a
good action if you're also
betting with a strong hand otherwise
it's an obvious Bluff so if your action
in some sense maximizes your
unpredictability so that action could be
mapped by your opponent to a lot of
different hands then that's a good
action basically what you want to do is
put your opponent into a tough spot so
you want them to always have some doubt
like should I call here should I fold
here and if you are raising in the
appropriate balance between Bluffs and
good hands then you're putting them into
that tough spot and so that's what we're
trying to do we're always trying to
search for a strategy that would put the
opponent into a difficult position can
you give a metric that you're trying to
maximize or minimize does this have to
do with the regret thing what we're
talking about in terms of putting your
opponent in a maximally tough spot yeah
ultimately what you're trying to
maximize is your expected winnings like
your expected value the amount of money
that you're going to walk away from
assuming that your opponent was playing
optimally in response so you're going to
assume that your opponent is is also
playing um like as as well as possible
Nash equilibrium approach because if
they're not then you're just going to
make more money right like anything that
deviates like by definition the Nash
equilibrium is the strategy that does
the best in expectation and so if you're
deviating from that then you're just
they're going to lose money and since
it's a two player zero-sum game that
means you're gonna make money so there's
not an explicit like objective function
that maximizes the toughness of the spot
they're put in you're always
this is not from like a self-play
reinforcement learning perspective
you're just trying to maximize winnings
and the rest is implicit that's right
yeah so we're what we're actually trying
to maximize is the expected value given
that the opponent is playing optimally
in response to us now in practice what
that ends up looking like is it's
putting the opponent into difficult
situations where there's no obvious
decision to be made so the the system
doesn't know anything about the
difficulty of the situation not at all
it doesn't care yeah all right my head
was getting excited whenever I was
making the other the opponent's sweat
okay so you're in 2015 you didn't do as
well
so what's the journey from that to a
system that in your mind could have a
chance so 2015 we we got we got beat
pretty badly and we actually learned a
lot from that competition and in
particular you know what became clear to
me is that the way the humans were
approaching the game was very different
from how the bot was approaching the
game the bot would not be doing search
it would just be trying to compute you
know it would do like months of
self-play it would just be playing
against itself for months but then when
it's actually playing the game it would
just act instantly
um and the humans when they're in a
tough spot they would sit there and
think for sometimes even like five
minutes about whether they're going to
call or fold a hand
um and it became clear to me that that's
there's a good chance that that's what
that's what's missing from our bot so I
actually did some
um initial experiments to try to figure
out how much of a difference does this
actually make and the difference was
huge as a signal to the human player how
long you took to think no no I'm not
saying that there were any timing tells
I was saying when the human in like the
bot would always act instantly it
wouldn't try to come up with a better
strategy in real time
um over what it had precomputed during
training whereas the human like they
have all this intuition about how to
play but they're also in real time
leveraging their ability to think just
to search to plan
um and coming up with an even better
strategy than what their intuition would
say so you're saying that there's you're
doing that's what you mean by you're
doing search also you have an you have a
intuition and searched on top of that
looking for a better solution yeah
that's that's what I mean by search that
um instead of acting instantly you know
a neural net usually gives you a
response in like 100 milliseconds or
something it depends on the size of the
of the net but if you can leverage extra
computational resources
you can't possibly get a much better
outcome and we did some experiments in
small scale versions of Poker and what
we what we found was that if you
do a little bit of search even just a
little bit it was the equivalent of
making your you know your pre-computed
strategy like you could kind of think it
as your neural net a thousand times
bigger
with just a little bit of search and it
just like blew away all of the research
that we had been working on and trying
to like scale up this like pre-computed
solution it was dwarfed by the benefit
that we got from search
can you just Linger on what you mean by
search here you're searching over a
space of actions
for your hand and for other hands how
are you selecting the other hands to
search over
so yeah randomly no it's all the other
hands that you could have so when you're
playing No Limit Texas hold 'em You've
Got Two Face Down cards and so that's 52
choose two one thousand three hundred
twenty six different combinations now
that's actually a little bit lower
because there's Facebook cards in the
middle and so you can eliminate those as
well but you're looking at like around a
thousand different possible hands that
you can have and so when we're doing
when the bot's doing search It's
thinking explicitly there are these
thousand different hands that I could
have there are these thousand different
hands that you could have let me try to
figure out what would it be a better
strategy than what I've pre-computed for
these hands and your hands
Okay so
that search how do you fuse that with
what the neural net is telling you or
what the the the train system is telling
you yeah so
you kind of like where the train system
comes in is is the value
um at the end so there's
um you only look so far ahead you look
like maybe you know one round ahead so
if you're on the Flop you're looking to
the start of the turn
um
and at that point you can use the
pre-computed solution to figure out what
are what's the value here of like of
this strategy
is it of a single action essentially in
that spot you're getting a value or is
it the value of the entire series of
actions well it's kind of both
um because you're trying to maximize the
value for
the hand that you have but in the
process in order to maximize the value
of the hand that you have you have to
figure out what would I be doing with
all these other hands as well okay but
you are you in the search always going
to the end of the game in liberatis we
did uh so we only use search starting on
the turn and then we searched all the
way to the end of the game to turn the
river
uh can we take it through the
terminology yeah there's four rounds of
Poker so there's the pre-flop the Flop
the turn and the river uh and so we
would start doing search halfway through
the game now the first half of the game
that was all pre-computed it would just
act instantly and then when it got to at
the halfway point then it would always
search to the end of the game now we
later improved this so wouldn't have to
search all the way to the end of the
game it would actually search
um just a few moves ahead
um but that that came later and that
drastically reduced the num the amount
of computational resources that we
needed but the moves because you can
keep betting on top of each other that's
what you mean by moves so like that's
where you don't just get one bet
per Turner poker you can have multiple
arbitrary number of bets right right I'm
trying to think like I'm gonna bet and
then what are you gonna do in response
are you gonna raise me are you going to
call and then if you raise what should I
do so it's reasoning about that whole
process up until the end of the game in
the case of liberatis so for liberatis
what's the the most number of re-racists
have you ever seen
uh you probably cap out at like five or
something because at that point you're
basically all in you know I mean is
there like uh interesting patterns like
that that you've seen that the game does
like you you'll have like Alpha zero
doing way more sacrifices than humans
usually do is there something like the
bratis was constantly re-raising or
something like that even noticed there
was there was something really
interesting that we observed with the
broadest
um
so
humans when they're playing poker they
usually size their bets relative to the
size of the pot so you know if the pot
has a hundred dollars in there maybe you
bet like 75 or somewhere around there
somewhere between like 50 and 100
um and with libratus we gave it the
option to basically bet whatever it
wanted it was actually really easy for
us to say like oh if you want you can
bet like 10 times the pot and we didn't
think it would actually do that it was
just like why not give it the option
and then during the competition it
actually started doing this and by the
way this is like a very last minute
decision on our part to add this option
and so we did not we did not think the
bot would would do this and uh I was
actually kind of worried when it did
start to do this like oh is this is a
problem like humans don't do this like
is it screwing up
um but it would put the humans into
really difficult spots when it would do
that
because you know you can imagine like
you have the second best hand that's
possible given the board and you're
thinking like oh you're in a really
great spot here and suddenly the bot
bets twenty thousand dollars into a you
know a thousand dollar pot and and it's
basically saying like I have the best
hand or I'm bluffing and you having the
second best hand like now you get a
really tough choice to make and so the
humans would sometimes think like five
or ten minutes about like what do you do
should I call should I fold and um and
when I saw the humans like really
struggling with that decision like
that's when I realized like oh actually
this is maybe a good thing to do after
all and of course the system doesn't
know that it's making again like we said
that it's putting them in a tough spot
it's it's it's just that's part of the
optimal the the game theory optimal
right from the Bots perspective it's
just it's just doing the thing that's
going to make it the most money
um and the fact that it's putting the
humans in a difficult spot like that's
just um you know a side effect of that
and this was I think the the one thing I
mean there were a few things that the
humans walked away from but this was the
the number one thing that the humans
walked away from the competition saying
like we need to start doing this
um and now these over bats what are
called over bets have become really
common in high level poker play have you
ever talked to like somebody like Danny
on the ground about this he seems to be
a student of the game I did actually
have a conversation with Daniel degrania
once yeah I was uh I was visiting the
Isle of Man to talk to Poker Stars about
AI
um and Daniel legrandi was there when we
had dinner together with uh some other
people and um yeah he was really
interested in it he mentioned that he
was like you know excited about like
learning from these AIS
um so he wasn't scared he was excited he
was excited and uh and he all he
honestly he wanted to play against the
bot he thought he thought he had a
decent chance of beating it
um I I think he you know
this was like several years ago and I
think it was like not as clear to
everybody that you know the AIS were
taking over I think now people recognize
that like if you're playing against uh a
bot there's like no chance that you have
in a game like Pokemon so consistently
the Bots will win the Bots have heads up
and in in other variants too so multi
multi six player Texas Hold'em No Limit
taxes hold them as the Bots win yeah
that's the case so I think there's some
debate about like is it true for every
single variant of Poker I think I think
for every single variant of Poker if
somebody really put in the effort they
can make an AI that would beat all
humans at it
um we've focused on the most popular
variants so heads up no limit Texas
Hold'em and then we followed it up with
um with uh six player poker as well
where he managed to uh make a bot that
beat expert human players and I think
even there now uh it's pretty clear that
humans don't stand a chance see I would
love to hook up an AI system that looks
at EEG
like how like actually tries to optimize
the toughness of the spot it puts a
human in and I I would I would love to
see how different is that from the game
theory optimal so you try to maximize
the heart rate of the human player like
the freaking out over a long period of
time I wonder if there's going to be
different strategies that emerge uh that
are close in terms of Effectiveness
because something tells me you could
still be
um achieved superhuman level performance
by just making people sweat
I feel like that there's a good chance
that that is the case yeah if you're
able to see like that it's like it's
like a decent proxy for score right
right um and this is actually like the
the common poker wisdom when they're
telling where they're teaching players
before the robots and they were trying
to teach people how to play poker they
would say like the key to the game is to
put your opponent into difficult spots
it's a good um a good estimate for if
you're making the right decision so what
else can you say about the fundamental
role of search in poker and maybe if you
can also relate it to chess and go in
these games
um
what's the role of search to solve in
these games
yeah I think a lot of people under this
is true for the general public and I
think it's true for the AI Community a
lot of people underestimate the
importance of search for these kinds of
game AI results
um an example of this is uh TD Gammon
that came out in 1992 this was the the
first real instance of a neural net
being used in a game AI it's a landmark
achievement it was actually the
inspiration for Alpha zero and it used
search it used two-ply search to figure
out its next move
you got deep blue there it was very
heavily focused on search
um looking many many moves ahead farther
than any human could and that was key
for why it won and then even with
something like alphago I mean alphago is
commonly hailed as a landmark
achievement for neural Nets and it is
but there's also this huge component of
search Monte Carlo tree search to
alphago that was key absolutely
essential for the AI to be able to beat
top humans
um I think a good example of this is you
look at the latest versions of alpha of
alphago like it was called Alpha zero
um and there's this metric called ELO
rating where you can compare different
humans and you can compare Bots to
humans now a top human player is around
3600 ELO maybe a little bit higher now
um Alpha zero the strongest version is
around 5200 ELO
but if you take out the search that's
being done at test time and by the way
what I mean by search is the planning
ahead the thinking of like oh if I move
my if I place this Stone here and then
he does this and then you look like five
moves ahead and you see like what the
board state looks like
um that's what I mean by search if you
take out the search that's done during
the game the ELO rating drops to around
three thousand
so even today
what seven years after alphago
if you take out the Monte Carlo research
that's being done at one playing against
the human
the Bots are not superhuman nobody has
made a raw neural net that is superhuman
and go
that's worth lingering on that's that's
quite profound
so without search that just means
looking at the next move
and saying this is the best move so
having a function that estimates
accurately what the best move is that's
right without search yeah and all these
Bots they have the what's called a
policy Network where it will tell you
this is what the neural net thinks is
the next best move
um
and it's kind of like a the intuition
that a human has you know the human
looks at the board and and any uh go or
chess master will be able to tell you
like oh instantly here's what I think
the right move is
um and the bot is able to do the same
thing but just like how a human Grand
Master can make a better decision if
they have more time to think when you
add on this Monte Carlo tree search the
bot is able to make a better decision
yeah I mean of course a human is doing
something like searching their brain but
it's not
I hesitate to draw a hard line but it's
not like uh Monte Carlo tree search it's
more like
sequential language model generation so
it's like a different it's a the neural
network is doing the searching and I
wonder what the human brain is doing in
terms of searching because you're doing
that like computation the humanist
Computing they have intuition they have
gut
they have a really strong ability to
estimate you know amongst the top
players of what is a good and not
position without calculating all the
details
but they're still doing search in their
head but it's a different kind of search
have you ever thought about like what is
the difference between the human
the search that the human is performing
versus what
computers are doing I have thought a lot
about that and I think it's a really
important question so the AI in Alpha
and Alphas in alphago or any of these go
AIS they're all doing Monte Carlo
research which is a particular kind of
search and it it's actually a symbolic
tabular search it uses the neural net to
guide its search but it isn't actually
like full full-on neural net
now that kind of search is very
successful in these kinds of like
perfect information board games like
chess and go but if you take it to a
game like poker for example it doesn't
work it can't it can't understand the
concept of hidden information it doesn't
understand the balance that you have to
strike between like the amount that
you're raising versus the amount that
you're calling and in every one of these
games you see a different kind of search
and the human brain is able to plan for
all these different games in a very
general way now I think that's one thing
that we're missing from AI today and I
think it's a really important missing
piece the ability to plan and reason
more generally across a wide variety of
different settings
in a way where the general reasoning
makes you better at each one of the
games not worse yeah so you can kind of
think of it as like neural Nets today
they'll give you like Transformers for
example or super General but you know
they'll give you it'll output an answer
in like 100 milliseconds and if you tell
it like oh you've got five minutes to
give you a decision you know feel free
to take more time to make a better
decision it's not gonna know what to do
with that
um but a human if you're playing a game
like chess they're going to give you a
very different answer depending on if
you say oh you got 100 milliseconds or
you've got five minutes
yeah there I mean that people have
started using right Transformers the
language models like the in an iterative
way that does improve the answer or like
showing the work the kind of kind of
idea yeah they got this thing called
Chain of Thought reasoning and that's I
think um super promising right yeah I
think and I think it's a good step in
the right direction
um I I would kind of like say it's
similar to Monte Carlo rollouts in in a
game like chess there's a kind of search
that you can do where you're saying like
I'm Gonna Roll Out My intuition and see
like without really thinking you know
what are the better decisions I can make
farther down the path
um what would I do if I just acted
according to intuition for the next 10
moves
um and that gets you an improvement but
I think that there's much uh much richer
kinds of of planning that we could do so
when the broadest actually beat the
poker plays what did I feel like what
was that I mean actually on that day
what were you feeling like were you were
you nervous
I mean polka was one of the games that
he thought like is not going to be
solvable because it's the human factor
so at least in the narratives we tell
ourselves the human factor so
fundamental to the game of poker
yeah the liberatis competition was super
stressful for me
um also I mean I was working on this
like basically continuously for a year
leading up to the competition I mean for
me it became like very clear like okay
this is the search technique this is the
approach that we need and then I spent a
year working on this pretty much like
non-stop uh can we actually get into
details like what programming language
is it written in what's some interesting
uh implementation details that are like
fun slash painful yeah so one of the
interesting things about liberatis is
that we had no idea what the bar was to
actually beat top humans yeah we could
play against like our prior Bots and
that kind of gives us some sense of like
are we making progress are we going in
the right direction uh but we had no
idea like what the bar actually was and
so we threw a huge amount of resources
at trying to make the strongest bot
possible so we use C plus plus it was
parallelized we were using I think like
a thousand CPUs uh maybe maybe more
actually
um and you know today that sounds like
nothing but for a grad student back in
2016 that was a huge amount of resources
but still a lot for even any grad
student today it's still tough to to get
or even to allow yourself to think in
that in terms of scale at CMU at MIT
anything like that yeah and you know
talking about terabytes of memory
um so it's a very paralyzed
um and it had to be very fast too
because the more games that you could
simulate uh the stronger the bot would
be so is there some like John Carmack
Style
like efficiencies you have to come up
with like an efficient way to represent
the hand all that kind of stuff there
were all sorts of optimizations that I
had to make to try to get this thing to
run as fast as possible they were like
how do you minimize the latency how do
you like you know package things
together so that like you minimize the
amount of communication between the
different nodes
um how do you like optimize the
algorithm so that you can you know try
to squeeze out more and more from the
game that you're actually playing all
these kinds of different decisions that
that I you know had to make uh just a
fun question what what id did you use
what uh for for C plus plus
I think I used a visual studio actually
yeah okay yeah is that still carried
through to today vs code is is what I
use today it seems like it's pretty the
community basically converged on Okay
cool so you got you got this
super optimized C plus plus system
and then you show up to the day of
competition
yeah
humans versus machine
um how did it feel throughout the day
super stressful
um I mean I thought going into it that
we had like a 50 50 chance because
basically I thought if if they play in a
totally normal style I think we'll
squeak out a win but there's always a
chance that they can find some weakness
in the bot and if they do and we're
playing like for 20 days 120 000 hands
of poker they have a lot of time to find
weaknesses in the system and if they do
we're gonna get crushed and that's
actually what happened in the previous
competition
um the humans you know they started out
it wasn't like a they were winning from
the start but then they found these
weaknesses that they could take
advantage of and for the next they know
like 10 days they were just just
crushing the bot stealing money from it
what were the weaknesses they found like
maybe over betting was effective that
kind of stuff so certain betting
strategies worked what they found is
yeah over betting like betting certain
amounts the bot would have a lot of
trouble dealing with those sizes and
then also
um when it the bot got into really
difficult all-in situations it wasn't
able to because it wasn't doing search
it had to Clump different hands together
and it wouldn't it would treat them
identically yeah um and so it wouldn't
be able to distinguish you know like
having a king High flush versus an ace
high flush and in some situations that
really matters a lot and so they could
put the bot into those situations and
then the bot would would just bleed
money clever humans yeah okay so I
didn't realize it was over 20 days so
um
what were the humans like over those 20
days and what was the bot like so we had
set up the competition you know like I
said there was two hundred thousand
dollars in prize money and they would
get paid a fraction of that depending on
how well they did relative to each other
yeah so I was kind of hoping that they
wouldn't work together to try to find
weaknesses in the bot but they entered
the competition with their like number
one objective being to beat the bot and
they didn't care about like individual
Glory they were like we're all going to
work as a team to try to take down the
spot yeah and um so they immediately
started comparing notes what they would
do is they would coordinate looking at
different parts of the strategy to try
to try to you know find out weaknesses
um and then at the end of the day we
actually sent them a log of all the
hands that were played and what cards
the bot had on each of those hands oh
wow yeah that's that's gutsy yeah it was
honestly and I'm not sure why we did
that in retrospect but um I mean I'm
glad we did it because we ended up
winning anyway but that if if you've
ever played poker before like that is
golden information I mean to know
usually when you play poker you see
about a third of the hands to show down
um and to just hand them all the cards
that the bot had on every single hand
that was
um just just a gold mine for them yeah
and so then they would review the hands
and try to see like okay could they find
patterns in the bot the weaknesses and
could they then then they would
coordinate and study together and try to
figure out okay now this person's gonna
explore this part of the strategy for
weaknesses this person's gonna explore
this part of the strategy for weaknesses
it's a kind of psychological warfare
showing them the hands yeah
um I mean I'm sure you didn't think of
it that way but like doing that means
you're confident in the possibility to
win well that's that's one way of
putting it I wasn't uh super confident
yeah so
you know going in like I said I think I
had like 50 50 odds on us winning the
when we actually when we announced the
competition the poker Community decided
to gamble on who would win and their
initial odds against us were like four
to one they were really convinced that
the humans were gonna
pull out a win
um the bot ended up winning for three
days straight and even then after three
days the betting odds were still just 50
50.
um
and then at that point it started to
look like the humans were coming back
um they started to like you know but but
poker is a very high variance game
um and I think what happened is like
they thought that they spotted some
weaknesses that weren't actually there
and then around day eight it was just
very clear that they were getting
absolutely crushed
um and and from that point I mean for
for a while there I was super stressed
out thinking like oh my God the humans
are coming back and we're just they've
found weaknesses and now we're just
gonna lose the whole thing but no it
ended up going in the other direction
and the bot ended up like crushing them
in the long run
how did it uh feel at the end like as a
human being what it as a person who
loves appreciates the beauty of the Game
of Poker and the person who appreciates
the beauty of AI is there did you feel a
certain kind of way about it uh I felt a
lot of a lot of things man um I mean at
that point in my life I had spent five
years working on this project and um it
was a huge sense of accomplishment I
mean to spend five years working on
something and finally see it succeed
um yeah I wouldn't trade that for
anything in the world yeah because it's
a that's a real Benchmark it's not like
uh getting us some percent accuracy in a
data set this is like real this is real
world yeah it's it's just a game but
it's also a game that means a lot to a
lot of people and this is humans doing
their best to beat the machine so this
is a real Benchmark unlike anything else
yeah and I mean this is this is what I
have been dreaming about since I was
like 16 playing poker you know with my
friends in high school the idea that you
could find a strategy
um you know approximate the national
equilibrium able to beat all the poker
players in the world with it you know so
to actually see that come through
fruition and be realized uh that was
it's kind of magical
yeah especially money is on the line too
it's a different it's different than
chess
and that aspect like people get that's
why you want to look at Betty Marcus if
you want to actually understand what
people really think in the same sense
poker it's really high stakes because
it's money and to solve that game that's
that's an amazing accomplishment so the
leap from that to multi-way six player
poker what's how difficult is that jump
and what are some interesting
differences between heads up poker and
and multi-way poker yeah so I mentioned
you know Nash equilibrium and two player
zero-sum games
if you play that strategy you are
guaranteed to not lose an expectation no
matter what your opponent does now once
you go to six player poker you're no
longer playing a two-player zero-sum
game and so there was a lot of debate
among the academic community and among
the poker Community about how well these
techniques would extend beyond just
two-player heads up poker
now
what I have come to realize is that
um the techniques actually I thought
really would extend to six player poker
because even though in theory they don't
give you these guarantees outside of two
player zero some games in practice it
still gives you a really strong strategy
now there were a lot of complications
that would come up with six player poker
besides like the game theoretic aspect I
mean for one the game is Just
exponentially larger
um so the main thing that allowed us to
go from two player to six player was the
idea of depth limited search
so I said before like you know we would
do search we would plan out the bot
would plan out like what what it's going
to do next and for the next several
moves and in libratus that search was
done extending all the way to the end of
the game so it would have to start
um it from from the turn onwards like
looking maybe 10 moves ahead
um it would have to figure out what it
was doing for all those moves
now when you get to six player poker it
can't do that exhaustive search anymore
because the game is just way too large
um but by only having to look a few
moves ahead and then stopping there and
substituting a Value Estimate of like
how good is that strategy at that point
then we're able to do a much more
scalable form of search
is there something cool looking at the
paper right now is there something cool
in the paper in terms of Graphics a game
tree Traverse of via Monte Carlo I think
if you go down a bit uh
uh figure one an example of equilibrium
selection problem ooh so yeah uh what do
we know about equilibria when is there's
multiple players so when you go outside
of two players you're a sum so a Nash
equilibrium is a set of strategies like
one strategy for each player where no
player has an incentive to switch to a
different strategy
um and so you can kind of think of it as
like imagine you have a game where
there's a ring that's actually the
visual here you got a ring and the
object of the game is to be as far away
from the other players as possible
there's an ash equilibrium is for all
the players to be spaced equally apart
around this ring
but there's infinitely many different
Nash equilibria right there's infinitely
many ways to space four dots along a
ring
And if every single player independently
computes a Nash equilibrium
then there's no guarantee that the joint
strategy that they're all playing is
going to result is going to be in Ash
equilibrium they're they're just going
to be like random dots scattered along
this ring rather than four coordinated
dots being equally spaced apart is it
possible to sort of optimally do this
kind of selection
to do the selection about
um of the equilibrium you're chasing so
is there like a meta problem to be
solved here so the meta problem is in
some sense
um how do you how do you understand the
national equilibria that the other
players are going to play
um and and even if you do that again
there's no guarantee that you're going
to win so
you know if you're playing
uh if you're playing risk like I said
and and all the other players decide to
team up against you You're Gonna Lose
Nash equilibrium doesn't help you there
and so there was this big debate about
whether Nash equilibrium and all these
techniques that compute it are even
useful once you go outside of two player
zero some games now I think for many
games there is a valid criticism here
and I think when we talk about when we
go to something like diplomacy we run
into this issue that the approach of
trying to approximate a Nash equilibrium
doesn't really work anymore but it turns
out that in six player poker
um because six player poker is such an
adversarial game
um where none of the players really try
to work with each other
the techniques that were used in
two-player poker to try to approximate
an equilibrium those still end up
working in practice in in six player
poker as well there's some
deep way in which six player poker is
just a bunch of heads up poker like
games in one it's like uh it's like
embedded in it so the competitiveness
um is more fundamental to Poker than the
cooperation right yeah poker is just
such an adversarial game there's no real
cooperation in fact you're not even
allowed to cooperate in poker it's
considered collusion it's against the
rules
um
and so for that reason the techniques
end up working really well and I think
that's true more more broadly in
extremely adverse serial games in
general but that's sort of in practice
versus being able to prove something
that's right nobody has a proof that
that's the case and it could be that
that six player poker belongs to some
class of games where a pro approximating
an Azure equilibrium through self-play
provably works well
um and you know there are other classes
of games Beyond just two player Zero Sum
where this is proven to work well so
there are these you know kinds of games
called potential games which I won't go
into it's kind of like a complicated
concept but
um there are classes of games where uh
this approach to approximating an ash
equilibrium is proven to work well now
six player poker is not known to belong
to one of those classes but it is
possible that there is some classic
games where it either provably performs
well or provably performs not that badly
so what are some interesting things
about uh pluribus that was able to
achieve human level performance on this
or superhuman level performance on the
six player version of Poker I personally
I think the most interesting interesting
thing about pluribus is that it was so
much cheaper than libratus I mean
libratus
if you had to put a price tag on on the
computational resources that went into
it I would say the final training run
took about a hundred thousand dollars
you go to pluribus the final training
run would cost like less than 150 on AWS
is this normalized to uh computational
inflation so meaning uh this is is this
just does this just have to do with the
fact that pluribus was trained like a
year later
no no it's not it's I mean first of all
like yeah Computing resources are are
getting cheaper every day and like but
you're not going to see a thousand-fold
decrease in the computational resources
over two years
um or even anywhere close to that the
the real Improvement was algorithmic
improvements and in particular the
ability to do depth limited search
so it does depth limited search also
work for libratus yeah yes so where this
deploymented search came from is you
know I I developed this technique and
um ran it on two-player poker first and
that reduced the computational resources
needed to make an AI that was superhuman
from you know a hundred thousand dollars
for the broadest to something you could
train on your laptop what do you learn
from that
um from that discovery
what I would take away from that is that
algorithmic improvements really do
matter how would you describe the more
General case of limited Dev search
so it's basically constraining the scale
of temporal or in some other way of the
computation you're doing in some clever
way
so like with like how else can you
significantly constrain computation
right
well I think the idea is that we want to
be able to leverage search as much as
possible and the way that we were doing
it in liberatis required us to search
all the way to the end of the game now
if you're playing a game like chess the
idea that you're going to search always
to the end of the game is kind of
unimaginable right like there's just so
many situations where you just won't be
able to use search in that case or the
cost would be
um you know prohibitive
and
this technique allowed us to leverage
search and without having to pay such a
huge computational cost for it and be
able to apply it more broadly so to what
degree did you use neural nets for uh
libratus and pluribus and more generally
what role do neural Nets have to play
in um in super human level performance
in poker so we actually did not use
neural Nets at all for libratus or
pluribus and a lot of people found this
surprising back in 2017 I think they
found it surprising today
um that we were able to do this without
using any neural Nets um
and I think the reason for that I mean I
think neural Nets are
um incredibly powerful and the
techniques that are used today even for
poker AIS do rely uh quite heavily on
neural Nets
um but it wasn't the main challenge for
poker like I think what neural Nets are
really good for if you're in a situation
where finding features for a value
function is really difficult then neural
Nets are really powerful and this was
the problem in go right like the problem
and go
was that or the final problem in go at
least was that nobody had a good way of
looking at a board and figuring out who
was winning or describing
um through a simple algorithm who was
winning or losing and so there neural
Nets were super helpful because you
could just feed in a ton of different
board positions into this neural net and
it would be able to predict then who was
winning or losing but in poker the
features weren't the challenge the the
challenge was how do you design a
scalable algorithm that would allow you
to find this balance strategy that would
understand that you have to Bluff with
the right probability
so can that be somehow incorporated into
the value function this
the complexity of polka that you've
described yeah so the way the value
functions work in poker like the latest
and greatest poker AIS they do use
neural nets for the value function
the way it's done is is very different
from how it's done in a game like chess
or go because in poker you have to
reason about beliefs and so the value of
a state depends on the beliefs that
players have about what the different
cards are like if you have pocket aces
then whether that's a really really good
hand or just an okay hand depends on
whether you know I have pocket aces
where like if you know that I have
pocket aces then if I bet you're going
to fold immediately but if you think
that I have a really bad hand then I
could bet with pocket aces and make a
ton of money so
the value function in poker these days
takes the beliefs as an input which is
very different from like how how chess
and go AIS work